hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I am just checking in on you
to see how your week's going and as you
can tell
this is a videoed one which means uh I
have a guest a special guest which I
only have this guy is a uh a multi
multi-talented
he's like an old school Triple Threat he
could sing he can dance he can act he
can do oh yeah they call him slash but
not the ones from Guns and Roses this is
the one from new kids oh the Steelers
New Kids on the Block Boston Zone
Joey McIntyre everybody here to promote
a tour that you're going on yes
um let's let's do that first and then
I'll uh we'll tell the sad story of how
we both ended up in each other's lives
um Joe McIntyre
ladies and gentlemen it's going on tour
he's going to be starting July 7th
through August 4th dude you musicians
when you guys tour you guys [__] go
out there grind okay now this is from
July 7th to the 4th I'm not going to say
all the dates but San Antonio Texas
Dallas Texas St Louis Missouri uh
Minneapolis Milwaukee one of my favorite
cities yeah uh why why Ann dot why until
which it's just outside of Detroit so
like on paper it doesn't look very sexy
but it's actually you know yeah it's
Hawaiian donut Michigan
as we all know Iron dot why that's like
a Jeopardy question what's what state is
Wyandotte in uh Toronto gonna take all
your money puts me a great time this
[__] Canadian bastards Verona
Cincinnati Evanston Illinois Atlanta
Nashville shallot
Alexandra Virginia Philadelphia and
Hyannis and that's right baby Cape Cod
Melody tents right all right little
teaser I might be in town I
say no more Bill the red carpet I'll
send the chopper for you
send it over to Canton so you can beat
all the traffic down I know take the
bournage you take the [__] Saginaw um
so me and Joe got to know each other we
did a movie called The Heat yes way back
in the day I mean it's already back in
the day was Melissa McCarthy and Sandra
Bullock yes and and some some Legends I
mean uh I always talk about uh
I mean it's sort of it's not it might be
a bit of a stretch to call that a modern
day classic I mean I get a lot of love
from that there's not a lot of Classics
anymore is that is Classics even a thing
and relax anymore I think somehow uh
uh people got a little nervous corporate
lawyers during this whole time of
everybody getting offended which became
really a way to get attention right to
literally watch a movie or a TV show and
say that you were you were offended like
yeah yeah it's funny how many people can
get offended by that but no like what it
was like they're not offended on how bad
they [__] over performers yeah and what
all these corporations do you see all
these people walking on out on strike
out here they don't give a [__] about
that no they don't give a [__] about
[__] keeping all the money so they
can buy another yacht that's totally
fine but if you go out and you say some
[__] joke whatever but I I think like
all of that's kind of gone away like I
feel like pulling off there's a cooling
off period I feel like it was a fad
not not being offended I feel like
people actually taking the time to
pretend that they give a [__] right is
is is going away it's right they're
they're using their energy somewhere
else but for a while they really put a
lot of energy into yeah like remember
when they were making all those vampire
and werewolf movies they just can't make
it one after another and they were all
making money and then at some point
everyone's just like you know I'm kind
of sick of these vampires and werewolves
so I think everybody's a little sick of
somebody
you know with their emotional support
turtle that they have to bring on the
[__] plane like I don't think he I
don't think anybody ever did care but it
was kind of like this weird period of
life should I care should I care no I
just think everyone's trying not to get
in trouble yeah
because you started seeing people in the
mail room It's Tricky out there taking
out the big guy up top It's Tricky It's
Tricky uh and you're going out there on
tour I'm going out there on tour by
myself
no it's uh it's good but but but to just
are you saying there's going to be more
a comedy classics coming around the bend
now because we're we're less afraid to
offend people especially one called Old
dads which is coming out soon yeah baby
would you think you were just gonna come
in here and promote we're waiting we're
waiting I was curious about that well I
saw you uh
the other night which was probably two
months ago yeah at my age yeah but I saw
you down at The Bourbon Room yes and uh
you like me you let me do the intro you
did let you do the intro you're you're
you're a sweetheart we know that bill no
matter how much you rent Rave we all
know you're a sweetheart and you you're
never gonna be able to hide normal yeah
you're not gonna be able to hide it so
for you to say let me you were kind
enough to come down and of course I
wanted to tweet it but you're so cool I
didn't want to I just wanted to can some
things just be private you know what I
mean do we have to post everything like
that bill Berg I didn't you know I got
you back I got great footage of you
introing me Sophie but for the for the
listening audience right now
bill came down to my Saint Patty's Day
show and introde me and it was freaking
hilarious uh anyways of course you know
it had a Boston slant to it but you were
about to wrap up but my buddy I was
talking about your Puerto Rican mother
my Puerto Rican mother my my my my band
my one-man band was out there and he he
had to stall he goes something's wrong
something's wrong we're not plugged in
or something like that that's right so I
had to tell you to keep going keep going
and it was it was quite epic so was that
that show that I saw the Bourbon Room
what would that obviously this tour was
in place these things take a while to
come together so was that no oh okay
well
that the the inside baseball answer I
guess is that it was a little rushed
most of the time these kinds of dates
you have to set up but it was a little
hectic because
uh it was it was sort of last minute but
not you got to find the right places you
know what I mean I didn't want to you
know they're they're like The Bourbon
Room which is like between 200 and 500 I
mean the melody tent is 2200 that's a
that's a bigger show but that's a huge
Place yeah trying to find the right
rooms and uh so but I think what you're
asking is it's it's that show I was sort
of work shopping a little bit as as like
a comic would do I mean I did uh like a
handful of shows at The Bourbon Room to
work out what what
set list this would be for for me to
take on the road so
um but how does that work because that
fascinates me
um I'm not much of a singer I don't know
if you ever noticed that but I was I
know how kind of how I put together a a
stand-up set so when you're going out
you know I would think that your fans
are going to expect you know some of
this stuff with your other band there
yeah you're also doing like standard
stuff that you wrote standards and then
I have my stuff and you know yeah so
it's it's a combination and um
I a little bit of this as far as my year
I started my year playing an amazing
show at Carnegie Hall in January so I
just I just turned 50 the big 5-0 and so
it's 50 years
wow look at you it's the uh full-headed
hair you don't have it you don't you
don't have any booze what take the
compliment take the comp you have no
booze weight you still have a nice
[__] chiseled Jaw well I'm I'm trying
to stay on the liquid death like you
Bill I know you I know you're one of
those guys like meh you don't drink
anymore yeah I just say I get I got [__]
to do you know what I mean no I yeah I
had kids I had to I had to stop because
uh oh dude I was getting [__] that was
I was drinking like an old school dad I
hate the big bottle of brown stuff oh
yeah and I was watching me TV and heroes
and icons and I just kept hitting Paws
going what kind of car did Ephraim
Zimbalist Jr Drive in this and Jack Lord
what kind of car was that I was in my
[__] glory and I was staying up till
like two in the morning yeah getting
[__] yeah hammered it was great I'm
not gonna lie to you being an
irresponsible dad in that manner was fun
yeah for about three weeks and it took
me about eight months to stop I I
identify greatly and uh I think once you
make the switch it's you can't I mean
it's it the good news and the bad news
is that I like oh I can't drink anymore
but then you're like wow I can't drink
anymore because you can't recover the
way you yeah I'm not like a full-on
alkie but I'm definitely I'm on the
[__] Spectrum towards full-on Alki so
I just know how hard it was to quit so
it's not like I like I feel like the
full-on alkies you know the guy with the
yellow fingers smoking the cigarettes
and eating the donuts and at the
meetings those guys like they literally
wake up like what's life or death the
shakes and and they're gonna keep you
know they're gonna keep going I I all I
have to do is just get it out of the
house and then it's like three four days
of like and then I'm just and then I
just don't think about it anymore I know
I know I the the get it I definitely
have a problem they get [__] I'm with
you bro I'm simpatico where we're uh
we're in the same car right now okay
um but I hate the idea of getting it out
of the house you know I do because I got
a nice uh you you were you were came
over the the uh the house uh recently
but I have I have this little closet
it's like it's got a sink in it and how
can you not have whatever you need to
make whatever you need even for the
guests so but I'm actually getting there
I'm actually getting there part of me is
like you don't want to be bummed out you
know I how do you balance the fact that
like you look like you look like you're
you you could have like a glass of wine
with dinner and then be like that's
enough
while I am a lightweight but I mean the
regard I mean I'm talking about your
capacity right I would never insult you
like that last name McIntyre I I assume
you can run the race I I know I really
can't no I'm an absolute lightweight but
still it doesn't matter to each his own
so
um you know what was what back in the
day what was it back in the day back in
the day right you're in your Prime what
was it what was your drink well
ironically I mean it was very it was
only a few months ago you know oh okay
but I mean no I can't do it the same way
I mean in Manhattan I make myself my own
Manhattan you know what I mean it's like
and it's yeah I go in the closet with
the sink and I make the drink and I I
sit back down and uh life is beautiful
for about 15 minutes don't you find
though like even just the the whole
process of making the drink in a lot of
ways becomes as fun as drinking the
drink having all the stuff absolutely
yeah hearing that knowing exactly how
you like it thinking about it on the way
home walking past family members the
things to be talking to you know making
a beeline they call it the obsession
right the obsession is the problem it's
not so much the drinking so yeah the
thinking about it is like can take up a
lot of space and energy you know I mean
that's my my part of my thing about
whatever the [__] is wrong with me is I
love the process
you know what I mean I love the process
of picking out a cigarette the right
trust the
[Laughter]
processities
I like the whole the the cutter the
lighter one yeah I I one time went down
a rabbit hole watching I can't find no
YouTube video this old guy did a whole
video on the proper way to light a real
Cuban cigar and it was literally like he
had a match and then he lit like a piece
of cedar because you didn't want to draw
the flame in certainly from a lighter oh
because it or from even from a match
because the chemicals that are on that
affect the pristine Taste of the tobacco
and I just sat there riveted and I
watched this guy
I mean dude he was he was just sitting
there going around the edges of it and
getting it going before he even clipped
it and he was doing it I felt like 20
minutes and then when he clipped it he
had the cherry and everything was just
right there and I was just like
I mean I almost think that if you if
you're like that serious about your Vice
you don't get cancer it was like cancer
respects you like yeah okay this guy
so and and you're you're that's a you're
a cigar guy now it's just like I am I
have cut way back okay and recently A
buddy of mine started smoking a pipe and
that somebody when I was in Milwaukee
gave me a pipe Bill if you started
that smoking a pipe man I don't know man
I'm done is that the end we're not done
I just don't know if the world and your
world and all your loving public I would
handle that they couldn't if you come on
everybody laughs but then they smell the
pipes and I think oh I love that it's
gorgeous swords and cigars I love the
small cigars I love that but I can't
smoke I mean I smoke one I'm done you
know I I've I got him out of the house
okay everything out of the house get all
your advice is out of the house yeah
because I'm I'm too old to get in the
car yeah to go to a bar absolutely to go
you know for sure yeah so sort of the
Last Frontier is uh because we got the
the kids are six and three so we have
this cabinet that has all the snacks in
it you know what I mean and I'm just
like I had to like I had to finally give
into the fact that there's going to be
snacks okay like a childhood for the
kids too without you know Fritos Doritos
whatever the [__] they want yeah cookies
so I just what I got now is I got like
uh
what I got oh my God this is this is
this is what it's like getting old I
have [__] raw cashews that's as good
as again and I go down and I take a
handful before I get into the other
[__] right
that gets it going that gets the
appetite going no that kills it that
kills it so late at night
a handful of raw cashews just the
sadness of that wow in pajamas just to
keep you I'm in pajamas standing in the
Little Pantry keep you ready eating raw
Something's Gotta Give You your Edge
rock that shoes I've had I I've had a
that whole [__] [__] East Coast
oh you got to stay back there and keep
your Edge they're really same stay angry
angry like me and lash out at people
around you it's like I don't want to uh
I don't want to do that anymore but I
will say I I still do have booze in the
house and um and I have high-end boots
for when people come over okay and I
sort of live vicariously through them
like a long time ago I bought a bottle
of Pappy Van Winkles which we I we just
finished it and it I actually would get
joy out of a more pouring a glass for
someone who's never had it wow here's
another thing too I only busted out for
certain people what yeah you know so
yeah the wife is like is he is he
earning yeah if somebody should I pull
it out is it I don't know let's see I
think he's gonna get a little Pappy but
uh no there's some people that they're
uh makers some of makers people okay all
right not everybody gets what now is
that is it like a spicy thing is it a
knock your socks off is it burn your
soul
okay I'm gonna get another bottle okay
and you're gonna come over okay all
right yeah and I'm gonna pull you
two fingers two fingers of course oh no
you would never you would never no do
anything with this okay and you're gonna
sip it dude it's gonna change your life
you're gonna sneak into your kitchen and
get a couple you're gonna buy a bottle
yeah after this Tour all the money you
make on this yeah you're gonna go out
and get okay that there's another thing
called uh Kentucky owl which was the
last thing I ever boost with
um was just uh you know it almost makes
you not feel like an alcoholic it's so
good like like the wine thing yeah we
know there's a whole lot yeah some
swishing it around and stuff that you
know and you're developing your palate
for wine you don't realize that you're a
[__] wino right right there's that
yeah there's that angle of of the
disease that you don't think you're
doing it you know you know that white
guy that big puffy white guy and he's
got like the loafers with no socks and
you see the fat starting to come out of
the loafers they live in that gout you
know the the the the color of that that
curtain behind it yeah exactly
yeah and he's just sitting there he goes
all about wine and everything and you're
just listening to the guy his heart's
gonna give out at any second yeah you're
like dude I don't want to ruin this
field trip but you are a raging
alcoholic
but they're happy what about the happy
ones God bless them you know I I'm not
gonna let you do it if if I never had
kids or anything I would have been one
of those guys that just dropped at 59
yeah and I would have been like they
would have been like you know this would
have been my eulogy you know he smoked
every cigar drank every drink you know
he he lived life this guy you're happy
everybody
oh man all right we got some reads for
the week oh look who it is freeze pipe
I can't make that noise
that's what I'm trying to do Jake house
Band Freeze Frame we get it Bill All
Right freeze pipe you know it's time to
enjoy bigger clouds without the throat
burn or coughing attacks for the coldest
and smoothest cannabis smoking
experience you need a freeze pipe man
bubbler or bong from freeze pipe why did
it take so long for somebody to invent
this this is fantastic included on
included on every piece is a freezable
glycerin chamber that cools Smoke by
over 300 degrees pop one of these
Chambers in the freezer for one hour and
as smoke passes through it insta it's
instantly chilled for an icy experience
that outperforms traditional pipes and
bongs
not gonna lie that sounds pretty amazing
start smoking like royalty
oh what is the [__] royal family had
one of these for centuries the [__]
start smoking like royalty without pla
paying a king's Ransom I get what they
did there by visiting the freeze
pipe.com and use code Burr b-u-r-r for
10 off your entire order once again
that's freeze pipe.com
f-r-e-e-z oh sorry the freeze pipe
the freezepipe.com
t-h-e-f-r-e-e-z-e-pipe.com and code Burr
for ten percent off shop today and say
goodbye to harsh smoke forever
all right who's all liquid death
everybody
I'm not just a drinker I invested in the
company uh liquid death you know you've
seen liquid death at festivals concert
bars even on Zoom calls I've seen them
at my grocery store death to plastic
murder your thirst they're cold tall
boys of mountain spring water will
brutally murder your thirst their
aluminum cans are infinitely I don't
even need to [__] read this [__] I
drink it all the time
I I just look at it this way would you
rather drink a cold beer out of a can or
a plastic bottle
[__] you to everybody who said glass I
know what you're saying all right but
I'm just saying if you had to choose
between the two
you pick the aluminum can right they
make Mountain Water flavored sparking
water sparkling water and they now have
iced tea three flavors Grim Leafa rest
in Peach and armless Palmer
uh do not compare to Arnold Palmer all
right those cans of iced tea are healthy
not loaded with sugar Iced Teas have a
micro dose of 30 milligrams of caffeine
per top per tall boy they're also
enhanced with B vitamins you can get
liquids depths healthy beverages on
Amazon or at a retailer near you and
Burr Tuesday listeners get 20 Tuesday
Monday or Thursday I would think get 20
off their first liquid death apparel
purchase available exclusively
at liquiddeath.com exclusions May apply
that's liquiddeath.com
all right and lastly but certainly not
leastly it's Gametime dot Co
buying tickets to your favorite events
shouldn't be stressful game time is the
fast and easy way to buy tickets for all
sports music comedy and theater near you
with killer deals on last minute tickets
and their best price guarantee you can
stop stressing over tickets and start
getting hyped for the fun you're gonna
have forget planning months in advance
game time has deals on tickets right up
to the day of the event the game time
guarantee means you'll always get the
best price if you find tickets in the
same section and row for Less game time
will credit you 110 percent of the
difference get images of your seats
before you buy so you know exactly what
to expect when you arrive tickets are
sent directly to your phone so you never
have to dig through your email snag the
tickets without the stress with Game
Time download the game time app create
an account and use code bird for twenty
dollars off your first purchase terms
apply again create an account and redeem
code Burr for twenty dollars off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest prices guaranteed man no
so um
I mean let me let me bring this around
back to my tour bill before that's why
you're here no I'm kidding but seriously
it is very topical for me because to do
this many dates
um listen it's not heroic I'm not trying
to I'm not trying to but do this
responders and there's Joey thanking you
on tour on tour let's put this in no
objective I keep saying it and I want to
balance it out but I have to live like a
monk I really do because if I want to do
what I want to do and do it the way I
want to do it roughly
um I gotta take care of myself I can't I
can't drink you know what I mean I can't
there's a lot of can'ts you know on the
tour to to be able to can
um and uh it's interesting I'm gonna try
to when you have your first drink I'm
gonna say right around Charlotte North
Carolina I got three dates left yeah
exactly exactly no the 31st no because
then August 1st yeah Philly Philly's a
great place to go off the wagon I know
and you're playing a white City Winery
City Winery I know I know I the the key
is to not drink after the show because I
think it used to be like oh I just did
the show I can have I can have a drink
but it's the it's the uh it's not just
the drink it's there get the drink can I
get that instead of just where are we
going we're just going okay you did the
show you know you did the show that's
the thing I mean and and what we do we
want I just said it to my buddy it's
like I want to put uh whipped cream on a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich like it
doesn't need it right right there's
nothing I want more Mayo on the same it
doesn't need any more Mayo right it's
like no Joe it's the the sandwich is
fine it's like you just played uh you
know Madison Square Garden there's a
bunch of young people watching this
right now going God it sucks I know I'm
sorry I don't want to be that way even
for our even for my fans my age I don't
want to be that guy I want you to come
to my show and have two martinis and
have the time of your life and I'm still
gonna have a it's like you pouring the
the the the Great Glass of scotch for
them you know what I mean you don't want
to be a party I'm not trying to be a
party pooper there's a bit of that
though they don't really want to hear
this
no no I would never say it I will say
this something that that a lot of people
need to know about was you had a show
I called you when the show was on and I
wanted to do an episode yeah but you
didn't get the second season no we
didn't get it he did his show what
network was it on it was on pop TV okay
it was just famous for uh shit's creek I
mean [__] they they aired shit's creek
okay well you did a show called Return
of the Mack yes yes and it was you
playing yourself and what it was like to
be like this this you was a kid became
famous there was what my favorite and
there was so many people Adam Raywood
Slayers Donnie Wahlberg was [__]
hilarious really funny like uh and and
uh Jamie denbo played the oh my God yeah
she's phenomenal which we met all we met
her on the heat yeah genius yeah there
was it was so good I lucked out I liked
I got to produce an EP like Eight
Episodes dude you were hilarious and I
loved how in this scene I remember
asking was like dude is that like a
thing and what it basically the run this
running sort of joke that you guys never
really addressed but you either figured
it out or you didn't was that women of a
certain age that had a crush on you yeah
and now in their 50s yeah come up to you
and sort of borderline assault you like
getting free feels and everything and
you would always play it up like oh
thank you yeah assistant they're like
touching your chest and everything and I
remember asking you like that's like
sort of a thing there's there's a demo
uh depends on uh did you already said
there he goes there there's that like I
have to walk the line here because he's
a loyal fan to buy tickets no no you
sort of get groped
um it depends on how much uh how many
martinis they've had certainly no my my
fans are great but yeah that can happen
that can happen depends on uh where they
are in the night I don't think Bill
Clinton could have answered that
question better thank you you you just
went right through that Minefield let me
ask you do you ever have nightmares
about you know the color women's teeth
turn when they've drank too many red
wines you know that yeah gray with the
red behind my lips too when you see the
talk yeah I it's like a Landshark Bee
Line for the other side of the room you
know try to uh no I'm I got I got great
fans so the the great great great
majority of my fans do not quote me and
uh they're very respectful and we have a
good time but it happened enough that it
was a running joke maybe you were
exaggerating but I thought that that was
so [__] funny I watched every episode
of that show
and uh thank you that's good and I've
been working with Adam Ray I still want
it like I write stuff all the time and
I'm always saying do you think Donnie
Wahlberg would do this because I thought
he was so [__] funny in it I know
he's uh he was very he and Jenny were
were the other producers on the show and
they oh they were came up big yeah they
came up big for me and they did
vignettes every episode and I called
Donnie for advice you know what I mean
he'd come up with these lame puns you
know what I mean you know uh it just did
that working class mentality take the
gig don't worry about it and I'd be like
they want me to do this Donnie and he'd
you know make some joke but yeah he's no
I I love it and um the last thing that
you know we've been talking about all
this stuff and we haven't gotten to the
real the real issue that makes us avoid
eye contact yeah guys uh did you watch
the uh Celtics yes game seven against
the Heat yeah yeah yeah it was you know
is that an important game I can't
remember yeah
um I haven't watched Sports since and
I've turned everything off and
at least I know I I think uh Reggie
Reggie Miller the uh he was he was
commentating I mean he was the one guy
who kept pointing out that that Tatum
got injured the first minute of the game
now I think we didn't have a coach with
the Experience slash guts to sit his
star player I know and Tatum wasn't
going to take himself out I mean listen
it's it's it's it's our team they're
amazing it's hard to root for them
because they really were so up and down
and it was not cohesive and yeah this is
this is what happens on the way to
winning a championship is you got to
lose some heartbreak in game seven
Castle why do you think Miami's [__]
winning I mean that guy that goes those
guys have experienced everything they're
a [__] amazing franchise and I'll
tell you what's wrong with the [__]
NBA is I've had like a half dozen of my
friends going oh my God Denver versus
Miami who the [__] gonna watch that
it's like why wouldn't you watch that
right you have an eighth seed yeah that
just took took out our number one a
number two and I don't know what the
Knicks were yeah and then you have
Denver who beat everybody in the [__]
West swept the goddamn Lakers they
deserve to be there but yeah
the NBA has built their brand on these
super teams and sort of like these super
team cities where I wish and I I hope
that they're going to get back to this
because I feel like the you know this is
the
the highest level of talent that's ever
been in the NBA because now that it
really is global now yeah as far as
where they're getting them but like I
wish it was more like the NFL where it's
like I don't give a [__] who's playing
in the Super Bowl I'm excited to watch
it right because they built their brand
on like anybody
you know like if the Buffalo Bills were
in the NBA they would have to leave
Buffalo like they just it just wouldn't
it's like we're never going to win a
championship and they'd have to move to
a city and be like the Clippers yeah and
be like you know the ugly stepsister
I I think it is a strange uh phenomenon
and I think you know the more we feed
that you know story that no one's gonna
watch is ridiculous but I I think you
know Denver seems like a Powerhouse and
I don't know but uh
I don't know if you talk about the
Celtics on your way to you know this is
what you got to do on your way but I
mean is it going to be the same team I
mean are they gonna pay Jalen Brown 40
million dollars next year I love the guy
immensely didn't have a great playoff
series so what yeah you still paying 40
million because he's worth it okay you
don't have an awesome show I do I never
tell a joke that bombs well the thing is
now like but yes but I was thinking of
that because I'm like I I think I think
you're very good at like taking people
out that need to be taken out but you
don't take certain people out there who
are showing up every day and doing their
job I mean yes if someone's sat there on
my show they'd be whacking me left and
right you know I mean take it down you
did this you did that oh you missed that
shot you missed that shot yeah if I
don't you break the two of them up
they need like we can draft somebody
what I guess nowadays you just go out
and go [__] buy somebody but like
um
you know you forget how young they still
are no they tayden played one year at
Duke and like how old is he now 24 25 25
yeah Jesus Christ what are you think and
they keep the same coach I mean I just
don't know exactly no but that guy got
thrown into it because the last guy was
yeah he's doing what the [__] exactly
and now he's going to be coaching
somewhere else
and we have Joe fascinates me he's like
banging people's wives like you you want
to take a shot of this yeah yeah
you can't do that
you can go to another city and beat us
you know with another team it's no I'm
just saying you know what you're taking
on when you bring the guy in I don't
[__] know all I know is uh the Bruins
lost to game seven and then I was like
all right I guess I'll watch some
basketball now and then uh it hurts it
happened again but uh but I I don't uh
you know I don't hate Miami or anything
like that and I just stay up whenever
this [__] happens it's just like there's
a lot of you know what there's a lot of
people in life who don't have a purpose
so in moments like this when they wait
for other people to fail this is when
they they try to fill up their souls so
like I'm just gonna stay away from that
because I don't want to listen I'm
literally moving I'm not even on the
internet and I'm just I'm just I'm just
pushing that away because I just don't
want to listen to like
[Music]
um
it's just like the lack of like you you
want your team to win so you can call
the other teams fans [__] is like and
I have to be honest is something that as
a sports fan growing up we didn't have
to deal with because it wasn't the
internet no salesmen had to listen to it
when they were making sales calls to the
team like I remember I was working in
this warehouse and somebody when we were
playing the Chicago Bears in Super Bowl
20 somebody
just on a piece of paper
because we sent some software to Chicago
just said let's go Pats
okay and then you oh I remember what
happened the order was [__] up
on purpose no okay not on purpose
because they were so busy writing the
[__] sign of what so oh maybe they
thought it was on purpose okay they
called up lit somebody up and then I
just remembered that we had a meeting
out in the warehouse no no who the [__]
did this
I'll tell you right now there's [__] in
I mean oh yeah the uh the owner came out
and he didn't say anything he walked and
you know you got the loading duck he
took the door went all right and slammed
it down
this is [__] dumbass tie and loafers
on ah
and then did he find the guy who said go
bats all I remembered is Bill didn't
talk I'd tell you that much he kept your
mouth shut I don't think it came from us
it wasn't you I don't know who the [__]
it was but all I know is there was
another guy in the warehouse that when
he slammed the door I could not look at
him I was like I'm gonna start laughing
and I'm not gonna be able to stop and
I'm gonna get fired and also our boss
was like five foot nothing yeah
um
so the whole thing it was just like it
was like a Will Ferrell sketch and he's
[__] screaming and yelling and uh and
I all I was doing I was just looking at
the floor and I was playing that I was
like ashamed or whatever but I was
really just trying not to [__] laugh
so that many ways that was like the most
she had to deal with now but now it's
like
no it's it's it's uh it's a dangerous
it's a bad bad neighborhood Twitter yeah
it's not you don't want to you know what
do you think I I feel like you it's like
three four days and what's the next
playoff series starts then they start in
on the other teams fans sure sure no no
no no the next 48 hours is crucial to
stay away that you gotta you gotta put
the phone down no question about it uh
and and there's nothing there's nothing
we could do there's nothing we can do
about it's done you know what I mean so
it's good Fellas yeah exactly yeah it's
the phone booth yeah exactly I'm glad I
I'm glad I know that was us
yeah there's nothing we can do uh so
listen it was a crazy game we got game
six uh I was happy about Butler I'm not
that kind of I'm I'm glad that he made
the three shots at the end of the game
you know what I mean so at least he did
his job but then we won and then game
seven
oh man
I kind of knew in the first quarter when
we got down by like six or seven I was
like oh yeah I never feel like when you
get down six or seven
in in in the first quarter of a game
seven I just don't I'm trying to
remember the amount of times people
start coming back like the other team
basically has to choke because I feel
like you just start to get tight yeah
like oh [__] this isn't going the way we
thought oh [__] oh God this guy's on
this you know when so when you have when
you have your best player and maybe the
best player on the court who's literally
not taking an outside shot because his
ankle her ABC I don't know you're done
but also my
back to Donnie Donny's gone to a lot of
Celtics games he's a big fan and one of
the things is he he went to the games
when they were 20 and 60. you know what
I mean so he's very knowledgeable he's
yeah a real fan and very knowledgeable
and always has a great take and he he
should do more Spot sports stuff he's
just busy acting and singing he's like
killing it yeah is he killing it in
other areas but I'm busy having a
monster career yeah exactly
um he's uh he said he was there uh
Courtside he said well I probably
shouldn't quote him because he's that
close though somebody who looked like
they were gassed they were he said they
were gassed in the first quarter they
were exhausted
they're exhausted but Joe the coach
wasn't wasn't playing anybody Pritchard
never came in you know the other guys
didn't come in bring those guys in have
them mix it up I don't know for whatever
reason I mean he played the same amount
of games that's what I said to Donnie
that's what I said to Dottie I said
Donnie you're always right but I can't
give you this one because he played the
same amount of games however I mean
that's that's what exactly we lost
because we were tired no but that's why
the rotation didn't come in think of who
they didn't play right they played Seven
guys instead of nine ten look at Miami
you know that coach had a lot more
experience but yeah I mean it's nothing
that was good that was gonna that was
definitely gonna catch up with us so it
did and it's painful and you know it's
so cool and all we have left is of
course
no I'm gonna take it to another level
all Boston has left is Joey McIntyre at
the melody tent in August that's all we
have left because the socks come out for
the ceiling
we got to score eight runs to win a
goddamn game yeah yeah so
I still love the socks though you know I
can be honest with you I kind of like
when they they're not that good because
I feel like it weeds out all the [__]
bandwagon people and it's just like yeah
I love hanging in there watching game
four the end of the year you can get a
you can get a decent seat you know what
I mean no no we're still selling out the
games you had seats for a little while
didn't you yeah yeah
me and Nick Carter we split season
tickets hard to handle right that's a
lot of games it was beautiful because it
was just we were both living in LA but
like yeah but you know they just won the
World Series yeah we'll be able to flip
these things about nothing we lost a
bunch of people to free agency and they
absolutely [__] sucked oh my oh my
God we I took a bath yeah I took a bath
and he asked me next year you want to
get Red Sox Seasons again and I was like
no I'm good I mean to it it's really
it's a full-time which killed me to say
that because my dream
as a kid was not to get into Show
Business was not my dream was to somehow
make enough money that I would have
season tickets to the Bruins Celtics Red
Sox and Patriots and I and I would
somehow I Would Not only would I have
the money to do that I would have the
time to go to all the games you know
what I thought you were gonna say I
think that's an amazing dream but I
think
a lot of kids dreams growing up in
Boston was just to be the ball boy of
the Boston Celtics wasn't that the
ultimate ball boy bad boy was another
one
but there was something about
the guy under the basket you know what I
mean the ball boy for the for the 80s
Celtics plus they were winning
championships that was it yeah so to get
to to throw the towel to Mikhail every
every time he went to the line that that
was that was the dream didn't get any
better than that yeah I think I think
that guy was like 53 at the time yeah he
wasn't really a boy well he wasn't gonna
he wasn't gonna give that he wasn't
getting my job up though he kind of hit
it you know I had um I had Don Gavin uh
one of the Boston stand-up Legends on
here one time and he went to like every
[__] Celtic game from the beginning
and he was he was literally there before
they won their first championship like I
was literally and I was so [__] up was
I didn't realize that until the end of
the podcast like I have to have him back
on to talk about that and he was there
not only at the Inception of the Celtics
but really the Inception of the NBA like
I think like like the first year
you know
he started going to games like the
Rochester Royals
which became the Cincinnati Royals and
she's still living the Kansas City Kings
which became the Sacramento Kings wow so
I think the Rochester Royals I want to
say either they
won the championship or Aaron the St
Louis Hawks
possibly I think that was in the middle
which we became the Atlanta Hawks and
all that not to show my whole nerd side
here that uh I'm into this type of [__]
so you know he was there when Koozie
retired and all of that and um
you know uh the whole like history of
the NBA was the Celtics beating the
Lakers in game seven at one point if you
can if you can believe that like Bob
cousy's last game was out at the LA
Sports Arena oh with the balloons and
everything right beating yeah the Lakers
yeah was in it right yeah all of that
game seven but the the story is they
they had all the balloons in a net
and they never came down because they
didn't win they had thousands of
balloons netted up in the sailing of the
Forum see my my whole life watching the
Celtics and Lakers as the Lakers have
gotten the better of us like in um
and then 87 they got us again yeah and
then after that then it became like the
free agency game so hopefully oh yeah at
some point we will uh
did you hit a lot of games with the
garden growing up League well they
always sold out so I only one time only
one time I scalped tickets really and I
I went in town and they were playing the
Pistons I remember Isaiah didn't play
but it was the bad boys versus the
Celtics but bird was there Mikhail
Parish original big three yeah and
Dennis Johnson and all that it was hot
it was like this you know towards the
end of the year or whatever and I mean
my buddy's like oh we'll just come down
here we'll start scalping tickets but
like you know I lived way out in the
suburbs yeah you know how'd you get in
there exactly you didn't you didn't
[__] drank a 12-pack and drove in
like everybody did yeah yeah you know
what I mean everyone was like [__]
wasted just driving in there but I I
went to way more I was more of a Bruins
guy okay so I went in and um
like I think the first seven games I saw
at the Garden was Bruins versus the
Montreal Canadiens because I love the
Rivalry and I love the fights oh three
four fights easy yeah good four I know
yeah yeah it was like uh the first one I
went to was a playoff game in 83 when we
were the number one seed when the the
president's trophy [__] choke that
yeah and then we played the Canadians
and they just came in and that was that
was bad
that was yeah Stevie Casper number 11
was still there but it was Pete Peters
it was
um um Middleton Barry Peterson was on
that team
Peter McNabb rest his soul he just just
passed away really
um yeah then when we got rid of when we
traded Riley
Rick Middleton Terry O'Reilly Wayne
Cashman towards the end of his career
Stan Jonathan those are the sort of big
bad Bruins guys after
um espo and all of them were starting to
get old because Terry came in after them
yeah Stan came after them when sync was
already retired so a tough guys
who the hell was it was that tough guy
uh I think that was before Jay Miller
and Lyndon Byers it was Terry O'Reilly
Linda Terry O'Reilly he's a guy yeah
yeah I don't know who was between buyers
and and Terry O'Reilly but uh Tom Fergus
with that wrist shot if he could just
develop that wrist shot he said that
Mike crucial nisky right that was a good
one Craig McTavish I yeah it's all
[__] up that old Mike O'Connell and
then Ray bork wearing number seven it's
so [__] up I can remember all of that
but I I like I don't care I remember I
remember how excited my brother was my
brother's four years older than me and
like that moment of when they they
retired number seven and he takes number
seven off and Ray Brooks we're in 177.
that was the greatest yeah that the
whole night was a surprise right usually
retiring the number is like you know you
know months in advance that was a
surprise yeah he takes off the jersey
and that was a vindictive move I feel by
by Harrison and that he gave out number
seven Espo's number that quickly do you
ever hear how we ended up on the Rangers
no they were [__] drinking one night
and somebody said to him I forget who
the [__] it was going like hey man I
think it was cashmere to somebody I
don't want to throw anybody on the bus
yeah it's Harry over there he's got all
this [__] money you want your best
play in the league you should go over
there you should ask him for a raise and
blah blah blah he went over and he asked
him for a raise and then like I don't
know yeah like that was it three games
later he was traded oh my God I mean
just think how many we could have won
and all that stuff and his brother was
the goalie right
yeah Tony yeah yeah Tony played with the
uh but more important more important
we're talking about the garden and I
thought about it recently though because
because the new kids first time around
it was it was it was when the nearly
years and the bork years and that when
when we lost to uh the Oilers but oh 90.
what what new kids without Wayne Gretzky
yes one of the many Glenn Wesley had
that open net [__] overtime I was
there in the triple overtime dude I was
I was you know what's funny is people go
if Glenn Wesley hit that would have
totally changed the series it wouldn't
have they were just too good no no it's
unbelievable but that if if as I say if
the
the red line
kept going up the stands my face would
have been red I was I was in a box I was
Santa right I said it bro wow and that's
what one of the many things that the new
kids got got me you know what I mean
with Boston kids and here we are like
the Stanley Cup for that game and all
around there was nothing better than
that it was the greatest so cool though
is that if you're like a musician I feel
like you can stay in like your hometown
you know what I mean and like where like
now I feel as a comedian and comedians
are showing this where you know once
you're kind of a draw you can kind of
make it from anywhere and live anywhere
which is cool because
um I can tell you tell you like if if if
I still you know I mean I'm rooted here
now my kids are in school out here so
I'm not leaving but like you know once a
year we go back for a couple weeks over
the summer and it's just like
uh it's the best well just as far as
being a sports fan I've been living
Behind Enemy Lines yeah like I was in
New York City during the whole curse of
the height of that curse of the Babe
[__] [__] and then right as I
move out to LA the Celtics Lakers out of
nowhere yeah heated back up again and
it's just like [__] it was the same yeah
dude it's just like Jesus Christ and to
sit there like when I go back
over the summer and I see people wearing
the hometown jerseys like I have to
remind my um yeah you know oh yeah yeah
like everybody everybody agrees with me
it's okay
oh yeah it's not your fault it's not
your fault yeah that you're rooting for
these teams so
um so tell talk to me a little bit more
like um
as far as uh like the show like putting
together a band and all of that like do
you keeping it simple so these are
intimate so I I I'm traveling light it's
it's more acoustic I got one guy I so
there's different colors and part of the
doing those shows in La was trying to
figure out am I gonna you know like the
Carnegie show was you know a nine piece
band it was a big deal but these are I
want to travel a little lighter so it's
me yeah this amazing guy who does plays
guitar piano I'm on the piano we do
acoustic we do some tracks it's a little
bit everything but the idea is I get up
there and I connect with the audience
and in a very intimate setting I get it
hopefully sing my ass off and yeah dude
you're gonna yeah yeah so it's uh
yeah it's uh hopefully I'll live like a
monk and drink liquid death and not
you're gonna we'll sh and we'll shake
off this game seven loss exactly slowly
but surely although this year this year
we have to say which one the Bruins yeah
at least the uh I think what you'd be
funny if we actually uh we two game
seven losses to the eventual Champions
because the Panthers that's one way to
go the Panthers I don't think Miami has
a chance against Denver I don't know
enough about who yeah I I all I do is
[__]
MVP Djokovic guys yeah I know right
Unstoppable I know I saw somebody the
other day was saying like you know Steph
Curry is a better shoot than Larry Bird
which he is he's the greatest shooter
I've ever seen but they're going like I
mean Jesus Christ he has like 9 000 more
three-pointers I want to be like well
first of all the first couple years of
Larry's career there wasn't no three it
was no three-point line and then it was
all about feeding the big guy it's a
different [__] game Jesus Christ it
is what it is it is what it is so dude
this looks like an amazing tour yes I am
gonna I I'm gonna you know yeah my
wife's the biggest fan like I know she's
literally said to me like I can't
believe it's been too she acts like she
doesn't know you listen and the new kids
got some dates too I mean I'm lucky
enough to be in a very successful group
and that's the balance of this thing is
trying to weave my solo stuff in between
but we we do have a show at the you know
the yamava they're like doing the ads
have you seen them no you know this
yamabad casino I'm surprised they they
have a call I'm sure they will it's a
new casino they have a lot of big axes
Billboards everywhere so it's the end of
June so you guys you guys got to come
out once and for a while wait a second
wait a second how far how far June 29th
and 30th and it's like an hour away it's
a hour outside of La all right yeah okay
we'll make it happen whether you're
there or not he's going to be there
how's that yeah nobody gives a [__]
about me although on Hyannis I'm I'm
gonna do everything I can to come down I
I love that you know why I love that
place
that's what the one and only place I
ever saw George Carlin wow I saw him in
the round he [__] murdered it's it's
a classic man you you still have like
cover bands playing there and God bless
them I'm sure they're amazing but you
have a great history there at that place
so I was like and they pack them in
because it when you're on stage there it
doesn't feel nearly as big I remember
when I sat in the crowd I remember when
I was watching Carlos oh my God this
place is [__] gigantic yeah and then
when I I was opening for the late great
Charlie Murphy and I was working with
Donnell Rollins on this Chappelle Show
Rich pitch tour we went and played that
place
and um I remember thinking like for some
reason when I saw George first of all I
couldn't believe I was in the same yeah
as George Carlin yeah it wasn't like the
way it is now where it's just like
famous people were like a million miles
away yeah and if you could just you know
be in the upper deck and I just remember
it it just seemed so much so much so
much uh um bigger as a yeah as an
audience member yeah and then I this
there's something when you get up there
it's like oddly it's it's still huge
intimate very intimate yeah it is it's a
unique spot so well I'm looking forward
to seeing you there and I'm definitely
gonna catch you guys if I'm in town yeah
um when you're out there so it's the uh
what's it it's just the joke
I like that yeah SOLO it's a fan that's
a fan thing like our fans you know what
I mean have you seen solo Joe so I said
yeah that makes sense
I don't know dude I'm getting kind of
like uh you know when Rod Stewart
started feeling like no when he's doing
like the classics and that turned into
this whole all right this whole [__]
thing let's go let's go you remember
that one I'm selling out the [__]
Mirage don't forget me all right all
right Joe McIntyre tour dates we will
have it uh up on the website you got to
go check them out and I mean he usually
plays Arenas with new kids you can
actually coming in uh see him in this
whole strip down thing like like all
these guys end up doing it Rod Stewart
Bruce you guys all end up doing this
[__]
I know why I'm pointing at you like I'm
being [__] rude what I like about is
is if you really couldn't sing and
really couldn't play right you would be
amazing this is the last place you'd
want to be exposed yeah yeah you can't
hide yeah no totally Mike up here so no
one sees that your lip sync is totally
yeah this guy is the [__] real deal
uh it's such a pleasure to have you on
here I know this tour is going to kill
it this is a great gift to get you later
that's right if if the birthday is
coming up oh [__] you know what my
wife's birthday is in a few days maybe
I'll surprise it with some new kids I
love it huh all right Joe McIntyre
everybody thank you guys for watching
please enjoy the music uh
um picked out by the newly married The
Newlywed uh uh Andrew thurlist then we
have a bonus episode of the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast have a great weekend
[Music]
come on it's Bill Burr and it's the
Monday Morning podcast for Monday
uh June 1st
2015. how's it going everybody how are
you how are things that is good
um I apologize
for uh last Thursday's podcast I guess I
recorded it in mono which was just on
I guess not stereo is what I learned I
don't know if I'm doing it again because
I don't know how to use my recorder and
I am currently not in the United States
so I don't know any nerds
um where I'm at where am I at right now
you asked
I am in uh Paris France
oh fancy freckles over here to get a
couple of macaroons there
steak and pump fruits
um yeah I'm over here uh
I don't know what the [__] what else am
I gonna do I tell [__] jokes in a mall
government takes all my [__] money I
might as well blow a little on myself
um over here with the lovely Nia and uh
we actually just got here
and uh we're gonna be here for whatever
seven ten days you know what's cool man
I'm actually gonna go to the uh the
Roland Garros
the [__] uh French Open on the clay
gonna go to the uh I'm gonna go to a
game at some point we're gonna go over
there scalp some tickets that's going to
be fun right talking to some [__]
French scalper
this goddamn Beret in a striped shirt
you really wish they'd look like that
but they don't so uh we just got here to
the city
um
about maybe 40 minutes ago
had a decent flight coming over here was
a little delayed but uh this guy in
front of us oh my God
you guys think I'm an [__] I know you
do I know you do I know you think I'd
give me a ton of [__] this [__] guy
was just one of the most horrible human
beings
who's the weirdest thing like he was
walking around like talking to everybody
just one of those older guys that just
talks all the time first of all when he
sat down he's got one of those uh I live
The Good Life guts or one of those
bodies you know with your legs and arms
are the exact same size like super
skinny and then he's just got this belly
um and he one of those people that
starts to sit down
and then the weight of the decisions
that they've put down their mouth just
takes over and then they just give up
they don't use any leg muscles they just
collapse into the seat and that's what
he would do every time he would he'd go
down about a third of the way and then
just free fall into his chair and then
at the top of his lungs would go
what he sat down
which to me was funny that was just like
there's an old guy he doesn't give a
[__] he's probably gonna have a couple
of something you know a couple
sarsaparillas on the flight but dude he
was so [__] rude and mean
to his wife he was nasty
he kept telling her to shut up like I
tell Nia to shut up and I'm joking
around this guy was serious
but what part he goes he goes he goes he
goes where are my books
and I heard her Mumble something I guess
she said what and he just goes my books
like yelled at her and then everybody
else he'd walk up to be like I used to
work for this place and we had a great
time there Jay you're cute he's a button
[__] weird as [__] so
um
so we're sitting there and we're reading
right fromage whatever the [__] they're
giving us uh I love her that's it that
that's their idea of a dessert
cheese
the [__] is wrong with you put it on a
burger take this back and go put it on a
birth right
um and then they have like a date and
that's supposed to be like your sugar
God knows you know that's probably the
right way to eat who knows they're all
[__] skinny over here but they smoke
like a goddamn chimney so I always think
that that's why they're so skinny so
anyways um
I'm trying to watch a couple of movies
but my movie thing every time I go to
watch it I'll get a half hour in and
then the dialogue gets like the audio
gets like five minutes behind
the movie which I guess I deserved that
was my punishment for doing my last
[__] podcast in mono right let me
make sure this
thing is even recording here okay so
um
I started watching uh Capote with the
late great Philip Seymour Hoffman that
guy was [__] unbelievable
I was enjoying the hell out of the movie
first of all because I saw In Cold Blood
a long time ago with Robert Blake and
somebody else one of the most amazingly
shot movies
um well I guess Truman Capote wrote the
book God knows I don't read so
um
if I knew a little bit of the backstory
and I was really into it and all of a
sudden the audio was like five minutes
behind
um so then I put on Americans sniper
and um
I was really enjoying that Bradley
Cooper was great he was picking
everybody off
I liked how they they had the uh
soldiers seem to be talking the way they
would talk the way they would talk you
know
a bunch of savages over here and animals
just the way you dehumanize the enemy
and all that type of [__] I was enjoying
the hell out of it you know and I also I
really respect I was almost going to say
archery what do you call it not that's
with the bow and arrow what's when
you're good with the pistol and the
rifle
what do you want a sharpshooter I just
really respect I really respect anybody
that is a master of anything and uh and
weaponry
I think it's just a really cool thing
you know what I mean being a [__]
sniper is badass
[__] nice throat shot just taking
people out controlling your breathing
and all of that I was really getting
into it really enjoying it and then all
of a sudden like the most you know
they're going after this butcher guy and
when it was getting really [__] good
the audio kicked out again and uh so I
was like all right [__] this whatever
I'm gonna go to sleep so I I start I'm
in the middle of sleeping and I hear
this glass hit the floor or something
and the guy it spilled his water the
nasty guy up front
in the room in front of us or he had
spilled uh
his wife had spilled the water he was he
just started screaming at the top of his
[__] lungs
it wasn't like every word he would just
like you know like the way he went my
box he would go like that
he would just be like oh now it's all
wet he just went yeah
I wanted to [__] kill this guy
he's just I
he was he was yelling like he was
walking around in his underwear in his
own [__] house and nobody would say
anything to the guy
including me I wanted to stand up and be
like dude will you stop [__] yelling
at your wife you old [__] there's other
people on the plane
you nasty God he was [__] nasty mean
son of a [__] then he goes to get off
the plane he's walking way out in front
of his wife and that type of [__] just
like just a [__] [__] complete
[__] other than that
other than that it was a uh a nice
flight over here so you know Nia picked
out this little apartment
little is the key [__] word Jesus
Christ
[__] thing Napoleon banged somebody
in this hey I'm telling you it's small
you know what I mean no seriously it's
[__] old as hell
and uh
so everything in here is like I guess
whoever owns this you know they rent
them out so everything is antique he
goes he's a real antique so he's like
he's a very very uh delicate so you you
sit down like easy easy easy uh the
table you you set the bowl Down Easy
everything's like it's like dude what
the [__] what kind of [__] apartment
is this I can't sit down
he said you know it's funny too because
his English you know he said the last
person who stayed here was very strong
and they kind of weakened the chair and
I wanted to be like you mean fat
but he was a cool guy man he's
explaining everything is that you used a
uh uh the stove and it has the day and
he would go da da da let's say yada yada
yada over here
and so anyway so we're [__] over here
and I'm psyched
um my whole thing it's my wife's
birthday in a couple of days so that's
why I brought her over here and uh that
you know when you're as big an [__]
as me you need to do [__] like that
that
shuts them up for a good ah two to three
days you know when you get back you got
a good two to three days where they're
like you know he took me to Paris I'm
gonna I'll I'll back off
you know trying to change him a bitching
about [__] and um
you know and then it's then it's all
back to normal and it doesn't mean [__]
to him other than unless you bring it up
which you have to do you got to be like
I just took you to Paris really three
days later you're still bitching about
it
you know you got I'm telling you like
you ever see like a boxing match where
there's a bigger guy he just sticks his
mitt right right in the other dude's
face that's what you got to do you just
got to keep that mitt right in their
face
you know
so anyways why would I do that such a
nice city and I got to take it to that
[__] level I'm really laying in this
this [__] bed this IKEA bed
next to something that uh Louis XIV
probably [__] I don't know bang some
horror on and uh they got uh I'm looking
out here the rooftops
we got a five floor walk up
each floor the the [__] stairs get
more like angled like you'd have to have
like 20 beers in you for these stairs to
look straight like like a lot of these
buildings over here super super [__]
old and they don't do anything to update
them they keep them all original
so uh they've settled for like three
centuries so it's really weird but I'm
up here
on the fifth floor and I'm looking out
the window here and all I see is like TV
antennas
it's reminded me that Flintstone episode
when him and Barney were going to get in
trouble and they were driving down the
street and he was last selling all the
the wooden TV antennas by the way
um off of the rooftops so anyways
whatever I'm I'm
babbling here this week I'm on vacation
and um
had an unbelievable uh unbelievable
month I'm still riding high on the whole
uh all those shows I did in Boston so so
here's the deal
you know I'm gonna spend like 10 days
here in France
and then right I'm gonna be home for
like three four days and then I start
another tour of the West Coast and that
ends up in Vegas and then Tucson so I'm
like well there goes my entire June
so I've been doing the helicopter
lessons and I was done I basically been
done with ground School
um
since like February but I worked a lot
in March and April and I was studying
for the written part of it so when I did
the southern tour I really you know that
whole month I was studying for the the
multiple choice part I should say test
that you had to [__] take and uh as I
told you guys I passed that and then I
had
you know I was looking at my schedule I
had that run in Boston and then my June
was [__]
and uh you know flying a helicopter is
like anything else it's like going to
the gym you don't go for [__] two
months You're Gonna Come Back suck and
win
so it's like dude I gotta [__] put
this thing to bed so I was just talking
to my instructor I was like dude I gotta
take the [__] check ride this month I
gotta do it he was like I like it I like
it I like having a plan let's do it so
I just studied my [__] balls off
this whole month while doing shows I
would literally be in the Green Room
like reading on [__] airspace and
when correction angles and all of that
[__] so long story short
um
my check ride was on Saturday and your
check ride is where you sit down with
the FAA guy
for like an hour an hour and a half and
depending on how you're answering the
questions depends on how long it is if
you [__] crushing it it's uh you know
could be short as a half hour if it's a
little bit longer
you know if you're not quite getting
them they'll talk to you more and then
if you pass that then you go out and fly
and it's all these different maneuvers
and
um
and then if you there's this weird thing
where you're either a fail or you passed
a bunch of things and you just failed
like one thing like if you failed your
steep approach or your hover Auto or
something like that you could pass
everything else and then when you retook
it you just have to do that one maneuver
and show that you could do it
so
um we're coming right up on it
and they end up looking at my logbook
and they realized that I was short on my
solo time and I was short on my uh
on my [__] um
nightfly
so I had to go down there Friday I was
taking it Saturday morning at 9am so
Friday night I go down there all right
around four and I just flew around the
traffic pattern
I needed a one point uh I needed a 1.4
it was flying around flying around tell
one time I scared the [__] out of myself
I was gripping the throttle too much and
I started my descent in the low RPM horn
came on and basically if that drops
below 80 you just fall out of the sky so
when that [__] thing comes on like
you just slam the collective down and I
couldn't figure out why it was doing
that uh for like this Split Second and I
realized I had a death grip
not really death trip I just had it too
[__] tight I just let go and the RPMs
came back up but you know I can just
rolled the RPMs on and just put it down
but you know it's the first time I've
been alone in the helicopter in the low
RPM horn came on and uh
you know I was kind of like you know I
brought it in for a landing and just
kind of sat there on the pad for a
second going like all right [__]
don't
Grandma it's unbelievable it's an
unbelievable experience I can't explain
it when something like that happens
uh it's like the adrenaline rush and
you're slightly nauseous and then you
plow through it you feel [__] awesome
about yourself
um so anyways
so I did all of that and then we did uh
I got my points I needed 0.7
so I had a total of 10 hours I had my 10
hours
of uh solo time and then I forget what
how many hours I needed a Night Flight
but I was like 0.7 short
which is uh
I don't know what is that seven times
like about 40 minutes
um it it means basically an hour I
believe
on the Hobbs meter every one is six
minutes there's ten ten times six is 60
minutes I think that's I believe that's
how it goes so anyways I'm uh
you know
flying around with my instructor and
he's taking me through the paces and
he's really really a stickler
um and just gets on you about everything
and I'm old enough to not be frustrated
by it because I'm like I know this guy
is being as hard as he probably being
harder than the FAA guy's gonna be on me
which is going to help
um come game time and um
so anyways we did like you know Auto
rotations at night
you know which is [__] because you
can't see where you're gonna land until
you get down there and the auto rotation
is basically if you had a drive system
or a engine failure
you use the weight of the ship
um to basically
and and the Glide Jesus Christ can't
even explain it here you want to
basically establish the 65 knot
uh attitude and the weight of the ship
the air rather than being pulled down
into the main rotor is now rushing up
through it and that's what's turning it
and you just keep it you know you want
to keep it in the green
um
and you can just you can just bring the
thing down and just like set it down on
a [__] picnic table when you get good
at this [__] I can't do that yet so
we'll do them at night I'm [__] them
up and everything I'm going [__] I'm
gonna flunk this thing
and my instructor's going don't psych
yourself out blah blah blah so anyways I
know I'm taking this out so anyways long
story short
Saturday morning I'm gonna take it I
wake up at like [__] 3 30 in the
morning I went back asleep woke up at
five and then I just you know I went
over everything one more time
and then I I went in there and uh I sat
down with the guy and I was just like uh
[__] here we go here we go I don't want
to flunk this [__] thing and then go
to Paris and ruin the first [__] day
of the vacation moping around ruin it
for my wife you know
so I sat down and uh I had a really
really
cool FAA dude and uh
you know we went through the whole thing
and you know I was getting a lot of
questions but I got I felt like I got a
lot wrong too but I got a lot right
and um and then he finally and I saw he
was getting towards the end of it and I
was just going I just I was going oh my
God he's gonna tell me I gotta [__]
take this over
and uh which is embarrassing because
your instructors are there at the school
you're gonna come walking out like I
failed
and um we finished and he goes all right
he goes that was adequate Let's Go Fly
and I was thinking I thought that was
horrific all right
so let me go out there I'm thinking like
all right now I'm two-thirds of the
[__] way there
so now we're walking out there we're
doing the pre-flight
and uh
I was just thinking of something my
instructor said was just like just
you know slow controlled movements
and I just made that like my my mission
statement that I was going to fly
controlled smoothly as much as I can
just to demonstrate that I had control
of the aircraft and uh
so we go up right
and uh we start and of course it's
[__] hazy as [__] it's the most hazy
goddamn [__] day I've ever flown in
I mean I couldn't believe it was still
like
visual flight rules like that's how
[__] hazy it was so the first thing
we're doing was we're flying up to this
place Rose Hills
to do these uh Pinnacle Landings which
is uh
basically if you're
it's like you remember in Mash when they
were flying around the Hollywood Hills
and they'd find a patch of dirt to land
on that's what you got to do so you got
to do your high reconnaissance first and
you got to be talking out loud going all
right it looks like it's hard packed
dirt sloping down like four degrees I
got trees on this side the wind's coming
from here sun is not going to be a
factor you got to be saying all of that
[__]
while you're maintaining your [__]
altitude which is you know not going up
and down and that type of [__] which is
you know it's not easy when you start
out
so we started heading up there and I
lucked out it was so [__] hazy we
ended up you know
he goes Turn Around take me to Compton
Compton has an uncontrolled airport so I
turned back around I'm making my calls
and uh
on the radio and I think I'm doing all
right and I'm thinking like I've never
gone to Compton this way
and I know
basically where it is
I fly out of Long Beach so I know how to
get it where I fly you know West Wardlow
departure and you follow this road and
you get to these oil tanks and you bang
a right
except we're north of that [__] so all
I'm doing is I'm looking for the [__]
courthouse so I'm trying to stay cool
and I'm like if I can't find this thing
I'm going to flunk this [__] thing
and we're coming through the haze and
all of a sudden I just see it sitting
right over there and
um
we did a couple of Maneuvers there at
one point I was so nervous I forgot to
do a clearing turn and he was all right
with that
um
I did a running Landing
um that one went great running Landing
was basically if you were coming in if
you were at high density altitude which
means the air is really thin you
wouldn't be able to you wouldn't be able
to hold the hover so if you actually
came in how you know your normal
approach if you want to try to hold a
hover you just basically you'd crash
um so what you do is a running Landing
which is you basically come in like an
airplane does it's actually one of my
favorite things to do Maneuvers and you
put it down on the skids and you [__]
slide and you bran gradually bringing
the collective down which is the thing
that looks like the emergency brake
that's your power you know you just
gradually bringing it down creating more
and more friction as you stop and then
you're staring you know the nose with
your feet and uh I did well on that
and um
I thought I did anyways he's not saying
[__] so he told me because if I'm not
saying anything you know that doesn't
mean you're not doing well you know that
that you're doing fine if you see me
writing down that doesn't you know I
could be taking a lunch order he was
real cool really put me at ease so then
I did uh
a normal approach and then I did a steep
approach
then we did The Landing off airport [__]
and then we did a hoverado and the hover
Auto
is basically if you were in a hover like
eight feet off the ground or so and
um all of a sudden your engineer you you
drive train system quit
um if the engine clicks it's going to
kick it the nose is going to kick to the
left and then you go right pedal it's
pedal saddle cushion is what you're
supposed to think right and he we just
done the the
which is basically you go right pedal to
get your nose straight and then you
settle you're dropping and right before
you hit the ground you pull the
collective up and that cushions your
Landing
so
[__] he doesn't and I'm thinking
pedals to settle cushion and he does it
and the low RPM horn comes on and I'm
trained like a lab rat to slam the
collector down so I put the collective
down and I was like no no no up up up we
landed hard and then he just goes now
why would you do that why would you do I
was like sorry man I got I go I was
nervous man let me just
you can ask him like let me let me try
that again he goes all right do it again
and then I nailed it the second time
then I was thinking like I just [__]
flunked it I just flunked it and I I the
way he said now why would you do that I
felt like I was gonna pass you and now I
can't
so
um
so then we got to do the last thing the
auto rotation
so we fly around we come in and he
counts it down three two one we do it
and uh for a lot of the time the [__]
low RPM horn was on but I kept it but I
wasn't losing it was just underneath 97
or whatever 100 and then I get it back
up in and then I come back down or
whatever I
but I guess it was good enough for
whatever so he goes all right let's but
I was I didn't know so he goes all right
let's go back to Long Beach
so I'm thinking like
uh [__] I just flunked it is it over I
don't know what's going on so we're
flying back and I'm talking to the guy
and he's like a test pilot for these
things he's telling me all these cool
stories and [__]
and uh
at that point we flew over to Torrance
we had already in Torrance where I did
the other half of that [__] so I was
just thinking to myself on the way over
there I was like you know what even if I
flunk this [__] thing how cool is it
that I I'm
I'm doing a check ride in a [__]
helicopter right now if you told me it's
a year and a half ago
I wouldn't believe it right so [__] it
just keep yourself in that mindset so we
ended up we go back
to the uh to Long Beach Landover at
aeroplex set it down [__] it set it down
real nice and he's not saying anything
and I'm like
I'm not going to ask him and then I'm
thinking well ask him it's not going to
change either way blah blah blah and
then I'm taking everything out and I
left the key in the ignition and I was
like ah [__] because he pointed he goes
you left your key there I was like oh
God
is that the Tipping Point what's going
on so you know put the wheels on it we
wheel the thing back
and then right as we start walking back
in he said all right you passed
and I couldn't [__] believe it I
couldn't believe it
um
so there you go
that was my uh
that was my Saturday morning
uh old freckles is officially a licensed
pilot and I am uh I am licensed to fly
helicopters
up to uh
12 500 pounds
how [__] cool is that huh so anyways
um
tonight I know what you think it's what
do you do Bill you're gonna go fly
around it's like no I'm not
I'm gonna go take the advanced auto
rotation class because
um
I don't think my reaction time I didn't
like it with the low RPM horn I didn't
think it was quick enough and I want to
get like you take that one like the low
RPM that I have to do now to pass my
test I just had to take it down to the
flare
which is basically you know 40 feet off
the ground gentle app cyclic and you
basically killing your AirSpeed and your
descent and you basically stop in the
air and then that's when we roll back on
the throttle we fly away the advance you
got to take it all the way to the ground
so then you actually come in lower
and then as you drop
uh down then you just like the Colorado
you pull the [__] Collective to
cushion it and I've watched these guys
do it they're [__] amazing at it and
it's like I want to be able to do that I
if I can if I can [__] do that then
I'll start flying around the LA Basin so
um for those of you thinking like Bill
you're already [__] mind I'm taking
it really seriously and uh so I'm gonna
pass that class and get 200 hours under
my belt before I ever take anybody up I
know but um I still can't [__]
believe it I can't [__] believe it
and that great thing now is that [__]
goddamn
weight is off of my chest I passed it
and my instructor told me goes this is
the biggest hill to climb as far as like
just getting your license getting
through just starting from [__] zero
and getting all the way up there but uh
I don't know getting instrument rate it
sounds like it's a [__] too it's
like 40 [__] hours of that [__] I
don't know about that one
so anyways I hope I didn't bore you with
that
um
let me uh I gotta read some of the uh
the advertising here
um
oh dude I am so [__] relieved
asked to thank [__] god thank God if
I didn't pass that thing then I'd have
all of June to be sitting there thinking
about it trying to cram in lessons thank
God
all right how many more of these [__]
things are there
there's two more all right we'll do two
and two how about that all right
so anyways I was reading another [__]
thing you know I talked about the baby
seals are washing up on the um
the shores of the West Coast because the
oceans have fished out now on the East
Coast
of the United States you got [__] a
bunch of turtles
are just dying off because there's
something like this too much because the
temperature went up there's too much
algae in the water which creates
something and which just gets into the
[__] turtle shells
it gets them infected and actually
paralyzes them and they just drown and
they [__] die
and
I I'm telling you I I think I finally
figured out why they never addressed the
population problem
and it's basically because the upper one
percent does not view it as a problem
they view it as an opportunity
to make more money
you know what I mean to hoard water and
do all of that [__] I was watching this
thing on the plane about cities of the
future that they're making I mean it's
app like the whole [__] thing is
total big brother they're saying
everybody is going to start migrating
towards the cities and you have like
[__] eight zillion people living in
the city who's gonna live out in the
country
you know those fat cat rich people and
you know what eventually it's going to
come it's gonna happen that it's going
to be illegal for a regular person to
[__] go out to the country you're
going to be shot on site
um
that's insane
what they if they really wanted to be
responsible what they would be doing
would be encouraging people to have less
children
let's level off at seven billion people
and let's try to dial it back
you know dial it down everybody has one
[__] kid
and then the people who don't have kids
or people who die or people who can't
have kids or gay people right
you know it'll actually cut off more
than a half
the way I look at it right with one gen
a generation could cut itself in half
and then the next Generation Cuts itself
in half and the next one Cuts itself in
half right and then after you know the
older Generations that had three or four
they all die off if you have like a
string of four generations that all had
one kid you can go from seven billion
all the way down to three and a half
million I think my math is correct on
that I don't [__] know but they don't
bring it up they don't they just [__]
figure out new ways to Corral people and
we're going to be eating powdered food
it's [__] it's terrible man I I I
don't know I don't have anything [__]
funny to say about it let's let's go to
something funny let's talk about soccer
speaking of billions of goddamn people
all right everybody in America doesn't
give a [__] about soccer you know what's
funny because that FIFA or FIFA whatever
the [__] they're called the FIFA the the
the the ruling governing body of world
soccer World Cup soccer I don't know
what they are I'm American I don't give
a [__] right I really don't I've finally
given up on that sport I sat down I
tried to [__] watch it it's so
[__] boring and the crying and laying
I know I've said it's a zillion times
I can't like if I'm in England or
something like that if there's a Premier
League game and I go there I go to the
game
and I'm sucking down some beers then
then I could get into it they're singing
songs and [__] and I just I don't know
whatever it's like you're in a pub with
no seats right that's basically what's
happening
well they are but you never sit down in
it so anyways
um
Darren they're in trouble
uh first of all this is how big soccer
is by the way football let me have some
respect here Call It by its real name
football
all right for all the uh you all the
fellow Americans that listen to this
[__] this is how big uh World Cup soccer
is they had some big championship match
recently that wasn't the World Cup or
maybe it was the World Cup let's just
say it was the World Cup
the worldwide viewing viewership was 3.5
billion
it was like half the planet they got a
50 share on the planet
all right and they I was listening to
the end something like NPR like put that
into perspective the Super Bowl had 150
million viewers
so if you're looking at it like a TV
show the Super Bowl would get canceled
it'd be an absolute [__] flop so
that's how big
this sport is and that's how big that
[__] league is so surprise surprise
there's a lot of people jockeying
to get the championship game in their
country there's a lot of people
jockeying to get the [__] TV rights
so there's a lot of Payola there's a lot
of Kickbacks there's a lot of coke
there's a lot of horse surprise surprise
so here's the funniest [__] thing is
they're being prosecuted some of them
like nine of them got busted in one one
network executive has taken up the fall
for an entire [__] uh
entire [__] uh
uh Network which is hilarious to me I'd
love to see what his payoff is after he
goes to that [__]
you know white collared jail it's
probably at the same place where they
play Wimbledon right and uh the the
United States Department of Justice is
the one pressing charges and I'm
thinking like what in the [__] how are
we involved in this [__] we don't even
like the game this is just gonna be
another reason for people to [__]
hate us but I guess they did all their
[__] with American Banks
so it fell under our jurisdiction
so not only do we not give a [__] about
the game We're Not Gonna
sit there and break their [__] balls
about corruption you know what I mean
because we don't tolerate corruption
here in the United States uh
everything's above board over here hang
on I gotta blow my nose I apologize
yeah the stupidest [__] ever
[__] zillion dollars at stake
obviously there's gonna be [__]
there's gonna be drugs
there's gonna be a lot of underhanded
[__] going on but nobody got killed
right
the only thing that really I thought was
[__] up was they they've been accused
of of fixing a couple of games I thought
that that was [__] up although if it's
done on a worldwide level
you know you do it in some [__] bum
country you know and I know you're not
supposed to say that but the fact that I
haven't named a [__] bum country can't
we all agree that there are [__] bump
countries you know what I mean because
for all you know I'm not talking about
York did there's just there's just like
you know what I mean there's there's
nice cars in this cars that's just like
this really isn't a car this is a [__]
box this was not done correctly you know
what I mean
the physics of it it's still [__]
working look I'm not saying the trees
aren't beautiful I'm not saying the
people aren't beautiful I'm just saying
the way the whole [__] thing's set up
or if it's being crushed
by uh more powerful Nations uh you know
I'll give you a pass [__] I [__] up a
hover Auto that guy gave me a pass I
can't give your country you know what
the [__] I'm saying
there's two shitty ass [__] teams
playing each other
you know what I mean to make an interest
interesting let's let's fix the game I
don't [__] know I'm just embarrassed
that we're involved in it and I also
think it's [__] hilarious
huh the rest of the world you bunch of
scumbags can't even run a [__]
legitimate League like we do here in the
United States the National Football
League there's there's an upstanding
that's an upstandingly it's all [__]
corrupt
it's all corrupt
we take money from [__] cancer to buy
yachts and act like we're [__]
helping out people who are sick you know
those [__] [__] over well we're here
in France what do they do right the
whole [__] bike thing is is is is uh
filthy from top to bottom Lance
Armstrong figures it out goes all right
that's how the game's played I'm gonna
play it better than anybody else those
[__] [__] they couldn't catch
them they had to wait to 10 years later
where they froze his [__] urine or
some [__] because they finally had a
test Advanced enough to catch the guy I
actually feel like the statute of
limitations sort of run out on that
um I don't mind corruption in sports
unless if you're like fixing the game
you know what I mean if you're actually
fixing the outcome of the game then that
bugs me but as far as like performance
enhancing drugs and like cycling I don't
give a [__] all right these people are
riding a bicycle 60 miles an hour up and
down a [__] Mountain they're
obviously on something and everybody's
on something all right they're all on
something
at that point it becomes
Fair
I think and I say let them do the drugs
let them do the drugs let's see the side
effects let's adjust them and then once
it's all safe give it a make give it to
a guy like me
right I'm turning 47 in a few weeks I'd
love to get the spring in my step back
you know
I wish it was a steroids for your hair
would that be amazing if you had like
like [__] Mark Maguire like his
forearms you had that level hair every
once in a while see a guy like that like
my age with hair like that it's just
like ah dude you got no [__] idea how
[__] lucky you are you [__]
um all right let me read some uh some of
the questions here for this week
um
bring up to 41 minutes here all right
Sinatra comparison a billy big leagues
this week on Billy check ride Oh Billy
big day uh I recall a few months back
you mentioned Frank Sinatra at the end
of his career well driving down Highway
80 I saw a billboard for the Silver
Legacy Casino in Reno
uh with you and Frank Sinatra Jr sharing
the same weekend as well as the same
billboard oh man I'd love to meet the
guy maybe this will drive you further to
become that slum Lord you've always
dreamed about being after you retire
from after you retire from Comedy I'll
try to take a picture of it uh the next
time I pass it can't wait to see you in
Sacramento thanks and go [__] yourself
well it's hilarious
um yeah I told you guys that story like
uh the way Sinatra retired the right way
the first time
and whatever that line he had that ended
that song you stand in the spotlight
it was something like Excuse me while I
something step aside or something he
just steps out of the light and that was
it
and he was gone and it's like that's the
way you [__] do it but he kept coming
back and it's just you know
and that was Sinatra Sinatra had to make
a comeback so
I understand how this [__]
this business works like how quickly
they they forget about you and all that
type of [__] so uh having said all that
I would love to meet Frank Sinatra Jr
I wonder if I can do that when I'm out
there
well I you know what actually in Reno
has my one of my favorite stores in uh
in uh in the country it's bizarre guitar
and gun shop I told you about this same
guy owns it it's a strip mall two stores
one side is this sick ass place with all
these guns every gun you've seen from
every [__] Stallone movie back in the
day
awesome guns and then the other one is
guitars and you walk in the guitar place
it looks like a normal place but
downstairs is where he has his real
collection this giant [__] safe he
has like the third Fender guitar ever
made just ins like
there was like I don't know there was
like millions and millions of dollars
worth of vintage guitars downstairs so
um I'm a big fan of Reno I am a big fan
of Reno I actually like it better than
Vegas
uh I don't know why I'm just one of
those [__] people I like the uh
like those kinds of cities better
you know the ones that are still trying
instead of the ones like yeah we're the
[__] everything's a [__] over go [__]
yourself you know what I mean
uh it's hilarious to see I like those
kinds of things as I'm sitting here in
Paris all right Periscope hey dear Billy
Gates
um I'm sure it's [__] annoying having
people stick their phone in your face
for the people watching on Periscope
that being said I think you would kill
it on there just once or twice a week
you should go on and rev your truck
engine while hollering in your southern
accent or pester the [__] out of Mia
it's Nia with an N people and the lovely
Nia
um n like Axel Rose
knees knees
um uh pester the [__] out of Nia while
she's trying to read a book
I love the podcast now I Periscope this
is why I don't like Periscope Periscope
is like so like
people just walk in Like Comics are
doing that now they just walk in with it
on look hey walking backstage at The
Comedy Store it's like dude shut that
[__] thing off
it's like if you want to turn your life
into a TV show you know more power to
you but like you know what everybody's
chilling out here it's like when I do
this podcast I I decide what the [__]
I'm going to tell you about and what I'm
not going to tell you about
and uh what I'm gonna leave and what I'm
gonna take out in case you didn't
understand what I just said previously
it literally just said the same thing
two times in a row whatever I don't have
my headphones on
my headphones are like my [__]
lightsaber it's my security blanket I
don't have them on I'm feeling naked
okay I'm feeling very fragile
um
for someone else to just come walking in
it's it's [__] annoying as [__] and
um I advocate the uh we got to come up
with something for people who don't like
periscope
I don't know what to call it but here's
a working title the Periscope slap which
is basically somebody comes in and with
their phone and they're holding it up to
their face you just [__] slap it
right down to the floor right and then
you do Bruce Lee's finishing move when
he kills him which is a Stomp and then a
Twist and you got to do the
oh when you do it
be perfect and then somebody else films
that
right no don't film it because then
they'll have evidence
um
you should do I'll just you know what I
mean you or you walk around with a water
bottle
you know you can do it for like a
[__] cat that won't get off the couch
and when somebody comes in just doing
Periscope without asking you you just
[__] you spray you just spray the
water and ruin their phone something
like that I advocate I mean last week I
advocated killing your boss I actually
felt bad about that because I just
thought about like what what if somebody
actually went out and did it the world
is so [__] up I could actually get
sued
and be like you know it was
irresponsible
but blah blah yeah you don't think that
that person's a maniac listens to a
podcast like hey go commit a murder and
then they go okay
okay you've told me to do it you owe me
money
um
yeah don't kill your boss but uh I
advocate slap slapping the [__] phone
out of somebody's hand
slap it right down to the ground stomp
on it twist it knowing full well that
you have to pay for it but you just
you're preserving your privacy
it's got to be a politically correct way
to say it you're a uh you're a privacy
Warrior
sorry oh [__] you you come up with a
goddamn name for it
um
all right you know what's funny is my
wife's birthday to uh tomorrow is her
birthday
and uh she's a [__] smarty pants and
she always figures out what the [__] I
get her and this this year I totally
threw her off
totally [__] threw her off
she's got no [__] clue where I'm
gonna take her what I'm gonna do well
she knows it's somewhere in Paris but
she has no idea and right now this might
be a lie this might be a lie just in
case one of you [__] decides to tweet
oh Bill's gonna do something [__]
blah blah blah blah you don't even know
what the [__] I'm doing all right
I can tell you right now I only have 50
of an idea what the [__] I'm gonna do
all right so don't even try to figure it
out
all right it's [__] useless so it's a
waste of your time
uh favorite music video downtown Billy
Brown nice [__] reference
I absolutely [__] love downtown Judy
brownie the biggest [__] Crush ever
when I first moved to New York
um
in like 95 96 I went to some benefit
thing
is hoity-toity thing where my manager at
the time knew a bigger manager who was
managing a big comic and we got the tag
along and I went there and she was
standing just hanging out at the thing
she was [__] gorgeous
[__] gorgeous all right too early to
get into comedy No Such Thing sir dear
Bill I'm 17 and just did my first Open
Mic at a coffee shop I got a few laughs
and a few awkward silences silences but
overall
uh I enjoy it I really want to go to a
comedy club soon so I don't have to be
so selective about my words any advice
to someone
this young looking to get into this P.S
I know bombing is part of the process
problem is I have paper thin skin does
your hide thicken up after a while of
bombing all right two things any advice
on somebody uh looking to get into this
dude you're already into it
it's like you just shot heroin now
you're asking me about heroin dick you
already did it now you're hooked and you
already want to go down to a comedy club
uh you started at 17 that's not too
early that's [__] great
and don't listen to the [__] older
people who are jealous they'll be like
dude you're 17 you you got nothing to
talk about you got nothing to talk about
and then watch them go on stage and see
what the [__] they're talking about
uh doing [__] jokes
wait am I talking about myself
don't listen to them all right
this is the deal you're young and
there's going to be a lot of people
[__] jealous okay and then there's if
you're a guy there's going to be a
couple of old [__]
lady Comics that are gonna try to bang
you stay away from them if you're a
female
um
you know just stay away from anybody who
tells jokes because they're all going to
try to bang you
um so [__] it's a job go down there
and get better at it surround yourself
with positive motivated people that you
feel are gonna make it and they're not
doing this just [__] around and
you guys will all feed off of each
other's Drive
um that's what happened to me in Boston
when I started I started with Dane and
Patrice O'Neal rest his soul and we were
down at Nick's comedy stop down on
Warrington Street in Boston we were down
there every [__] night unless we had
a gig elsewhere and even then a lot of
times we would drive back in there we
were there every [__] night
and um
I remember one of the great compliments
I got when I first started out this guy
came walking in and I was like and I was
already there you know writing down my
jokes and he looked at me said dude you
are everywhere and it's just like yeah
yeah I am so that's what you got to be
dude and you can't just do like Club
comedy clubs you gotta do stand up any
way you can and as far as bombing yes it
is part of the process ever you know I
had a paper thin skin
I was shy I was introverted I had all of
that and it just was [__] all when
you bomb it was just ah just sucks it
just sucks in the beginning but
um
the same way you learn how to kill
you're going to learn how to bomb and
you're gonna learn how to
how to um
like have hold your uh hold your ground
and you'll have you'll have Poise while
uh bombing and then when you get to a
really high level of bombing is you'll
uh you'll be begin to understand if
you're bombing because if it's your
fault if it's the crowd's fault if it's
the setup if it's half the crowd half
you if it's 60 percent you and that that
to me is the best thing when
if you figure out it's you then you just
start making fun of yourself if you
figure out it's them you start giving
them [__] and they loosen up a little
bit
um if it's a little bit in the middle
you sort of make fun of yourself while
you're ripping them you'll figure out
the whole recipe to the thing but um
you know I think it's great you're
starting it takes a lot of balls 17 to
start out so uh my my [__] uh my hat
is off to you all right
helicopter loser
High Bill and in quotes it said oh my
God I'm a loser I'll never own a
helicopter I'm a disgrace
and they said that's from Bill Burr
emotionally unavailable that's quoting
one of my jokes he said do you remember
saying this during the MTV Cribs bit
I feel like you made it now Big Shot
helicopter guy go [__] yourself but
seriously well done on the helicopter
driving thank you
um oh yeah I remember that bit I didn't
know that I said helicopter but I
remember uh talking about how MTV Cribs
how you would watch that show and you
just end up feeling like a [__] loser
because it was all like these you know
am I really gonna say Britney Spears
twice in this [__] podcast yes it is
2015. um
all those [__] people's houses back
then Cisco's house the one hit wonders
too they all had Bentleys and all of
this [__] and it made you feel like a
loser here's a [__] inside joke uh
Inside Story on on that
all right
when I did that bit
um
one night I did it at The Comedy Cellar
in the late great Greg Giraldo rest his
soul
he came up to me after I did the bit he
goes dude he goes just to let you know
I have a bit on MTV Cribs and it's
almost word for word the exact same bit
it's the exact same angle and both of us
were just in a part of our career where
we were writing our hours and we I
didn't have anything else I was just
like ah man he's
as like neither one of us wanted to draw
you have to have the conversation
usually someone's like I'll drop it no
you do it no no you know
and I've usually been the one that I was
always like I'll drop it I'll drop it
because I didn't want any of my [__]
you know
somebody else seen somebody else doing
and thinking I'm stealing so we both
just sat there going like stare at the
floor and then we both just started
laughing going like all right we'll only
do that joke on the road so me and
Geraldo had this this uh gentleman's
agreement that even though we didn't
steal from each other but we basically
had the exact same bit
um that we would only do it on the road
so that's what happened and we never
really talked about it again
and we both just kind of forgot that we
kind of had the same joke and then like
the same season we both got a half hour
on Comedy Central
both did the bit
and I remember my special came out first
and I remember getting an email and
somebody going hey bro just to let you
know Greg Giraldo stole your stole your
MTV Cribs bit and I went like oh [__]
that's right he's got the same thing so
I emailed the kid back told him the
story and then I called Geraldo and we
both just started laughing and we're
trying to guess which one of us was
going to be you know
called a joke Thief more wow that was
wow that was way back Way Way Back
it was like 2002.
um
oh my God I'm a loser I'll never own a
helicopter just Christ Jesus Christ
that's [__]
I remember saying that here I am years
later years later years later
um all right let me read a couple more
of these uh these these advertising
things here then I can wrap this podcast
up and hopefully
I'll be able to upload this with the
Euro [__] internet here
please tell me that's not wind chimes
is that a [__] telephone
I'm not answering that [__]
hello this is Louis
all right
there we go so before I check out here
and uh
begin my [__] vacation here
what are you gonna do Bill you know what
I'm gonna do I'm not doing [__] I'm
gonna sit in the cafes
and uh
I don't know I need some [__] some of
their food
I forget what that beer was that I liked
the last time I was over here I'm
looking forward to doing that but uh to
be honest with you I just want to chill
out not be an [__] and make sure my
wife has a good time to be honest with
you that's going to be my attempt
because I don't want to end up like that
guy
that guy was so I was [__] depressing
I felt bad like his wife was just
sitting there taking it one of those old
school [__] women
just
someone needed to take her aside and be
like you can't take this from this guy
[__] slap him around or something I
don't know what so anyways let's talk
about the NHL finals which I'm gonna
[__] miss over here unless I can find
an NHL bar
um
I know I know you can watch it online
with the password and I'll probably [__]
it up
but anyways uh Blackhawks
first the Tampa Bay Lightning
um
I'm gonna tell you something right now
Jonathan Taves that guy
he is in the process of uh
being one of those guys who they're
going to be selling his jersey like 20
years from now
and little kids in 20 years they're
going to know who he is that [__] guy
like
he's just a man that guy just [__]
steps up that game seven against the
Ducks and congratulations to the Ducks
too and what is what what a season they
had
just a great [__] team
um
and uh just game seven
they're on the road in Anaheim and just
right in the first two minutes just
shuts the crowd the [__] up with a goal
and then scores another one
end of first period it's two to nothing
and tave scored both [__] goals it's
just the guy is he's just he's the [__]
so
I don't know uh
who isn't a fan of greatness so this
usually I like the underdog and I I like
Tampa Bay and I really like you know
Steve Eisman and everything that he's
done with that thing so if Tampa Bay Bay
wins I'll be I'll also be happy but like
uh I I just obviously
just having a player like Taves get a
third is uh it's great for the game and
it's also great for Chicago because then
now you know when they do their
their whole like the great people of uh
who are the greats of Chicago sports
right Bobby Hull
Michael Jordan I'm sorry Walter Payton
Michael Jordan
and then Taves is going to be right in
there right he gets his third
um
wait we gotta they gotta have a great
Ernie Banks
who's a great white sock I don't know
that Shoeless Joe Jackson from the
[__] black socks I hate that they
call them the black socks it's like no
they were the [__] White Sox
I think they fixed the World Series now
that my friends that was cheating
[__] air pressure I'll never get over
it I'll never get over it anyways
um
so obviously I think the Blackhawks are
going to win just because they're so
deep in the uh
the uh experience they have but I'm
really bummed out that I'm not gonna
[__] see it
um
I'll figure out a [__] way to do it
and then what's the other one we got
here oh let me sit in this [__]
antique chair I hope it doesn't break
um
who else is it oh LeBron
of course what's his face Steph Curry
I don't know [__] about basketball all I
know is Curry's one of the most amazing
basketball players I've ever seen in my
life but I gotta be honest with you I am
so sick of a close-up on his face while
he's chewing his mouthpiece it's [__]
gross
okay just keep it you [__] I hate
that [__] you know what it's gonna do
because he's so good it's gonna Inspire
an entire generation of young kids to
walk around with their chewing on their
[__] mouthpiece after every [__]
play because they want to be like him
you know remember when you want to be
like Mike you just stuck your tongue out
and try to dunk as you floated in
sideways then you just uh tripped and
fell
uh now they're gonna have the [__]
that thing hanging out of their mouth
but um
I don't know who the roach root for
there I love the whole thing that LeBron
came back
and one one for [__] Cleveland they
could finally put their [__] whining
all the time about how awful their
Sports situation is
but then on the other side I like Golden
State man Golden State to me like uh
that team is like uh what was that Will
Ferrell movie
Semi-Pro
like to me golden state is like
you got the sickest floor in the NBA but
before they had a man like where they
play is just old school sports there's
not a lot of venues like that anymore I
went to a game there a long time ago
when they played the Spurs uh David
Robinson was still on the team he was in
street closer and uh what's his face was
really young uh Captain the big
fundamental there whatever the [__] his
name is
um but anyways they are the sickest live
band there so
you know what ah this is tough I think I
gotta go I gotta go for the Warriors you
know why because Al Madrigal is a
Warriors fan and he's the [__]
driving force behind the all things
Comedy Network there you go that tipped
it in favor I know you're like what
about Jason lawhead what about Jason
lawhead well you know what the Buckeyes
won it this year so he's already got a
championship so I'm rooting for the
Warriors there you go I'm rooting for
the Warriors and I'm rooting for the
Blackhawks the greatness of uh Jonathan
Taves I want to see uh I want to see him
get his third one and uh plus original
six and I also gotta be honest with you
the [__] Blackhawks that that home
Jersey which used to be the way that red
one that's one of the best jerseys in
all of [__] Sports all right that's
the deal everybody uh thank you to
everybody that's listening I'm in a
generous move here I'm still gonna tell
you go [__] yourselves but uh I'm just
so [__] psyched I finally got the
helicopter thing
um done and then I can now go on to uh
actually really learn how to fly the
[__] thing which is really what your
pilot's license is it's a license to
learn they say so I got to get on that
[__] so that is it I'm gonna do another
goddamn Comedy Jam coming up this month
uh so I gotta get my drumming chops back
together I've been nothing but
helicopters this month so uh brought my
little [__] pad over here you know
I'm gonna Peril diddle my [__] way
back in this drumming shape but when I
come back I forget what date that is uh
but they'll have it up on their website
as always please